so this is making the rounds we found
out we
just might be siblings but we're still
dating hmm
funny
yes but not funny haha
funny weird
their [ __ ] look alike
they look alike but but then again it
could be i know some people that date
each other and they look alike and they
have no relation
all gonna be safe
and we're all gonna have a great time
what the jesus christ was that past
sister so they have the same mother for
example listen they're simplex
okay they are so the internet lost its
mind because they kept dating like oh
this is intellisense right
so everyone's losing their minds
fascinating to watch and then i click on
their bio and they got only things
profitable
you understand yeah i do right
you know
you go on
hornob and
stepsisters
is a whole category but it might be true
is it true
it's only fans yeah but these
[ __ ] look alike
it's the only thing i understand what
you said right but what helps also is
that these [ __ ] look alike yeah
but all these [ __ ] look like too
not like white people
i'm just saying
the odds of them
dating and then finding out that they're
half siblings and also doing only fans
and they continue it's a lot it's a lot
marketing sounds perfect yes right and
you have to imagine people like these
kind of characters yeah they like this
kind of yeah write all this profitable i
guarantee you when this story broke out
and went viral like it did guess what
[ __ ] went ewe
jay they pulled that [ __ ] out real quick
and i'm not just talking about their
phones disgusting
okay
so you can imagine that a lot of these
stories when you're hearing them for the
first time
everything that we create today a lot of
stuff whether it be on youtube or news
and stuff a lot of it is just
it's just centered around outreach
even the reason why you clicked this
video you saw the headline you saw the
whole thing like ew right it makes
perfect sense i understand why but you
have to imagine people are feeding off
your propensity to look for that stuff
to drive money to their pockets and i
i'm not going to send you but
we're probably part of that too you know
we try to go for salacious titles and
stuff like that what's the only
difference is we try not to lie but
we're not trying to make up a world
we're actually the opposite of these two
girls these two girls are siblings and
[ __ ] with each other we're not
friends
when you said you were the opposite i
would stand you like [ __ ] what kind of
weird [ __ ] you about to say right now
you better be careful i was careful yes
you can you pass because if we don't
cause if we don't if we don't film i
don't see you yeah facts
i did this thing on my instagram
[ __ ] like
they asked me questions right and
[ __ ] like yo is i was single
and i was like
i don't know
i don't know
i don't know
and you won't find out hey you won't
find out yeah one day you just gonna go
to the wedding i'm probably not going to
get an invitation to the wedding
hey guess what
it's fine
you'll get one you'll get one all right
if i if i satisfied all right cool
pretty's like well i'm not inviting you
to my [ __ ]
video is brought to you by surfsharkvpn
a vpn is an application or an extension
that you put on top of your browser in
order to change or to mask your ip
address you know to change the location
of your computer why would you want to
do that well sometimes i want to listen
to other content from other country and
they won't let me in knock knock who's
there canada won't let you in unless
you're from the uk
switch the vpn changer and then boom
knock knock who's there
it's actually the uk now
yes come in lord come have some tea i
know you guys don't speak like that but
you know what i mean so you're able to
watch much more content and then boom
the world is open to you just like
aladdin on a carpet i can show you the
world and for the next months you have
83
off and the three next month's three if
you use abba and preach code a
surfsharkvpn use the link below go ahead
on this topic what do you think about
siblings and stuff like that i don't
care i don't care but you don't think
like them having kids and the genetic
defects are weird but there's some
people that are not they're not siblings
that have weird [ __ ] kids i would
argue this go ahead
having kids and drinking alcohol like
lots of alcohol
why what i'll drink alcohol while having
kids while being pregnant what would you
feel about that
lots of it
i really feel like it's none of my
business
like
okay let me rephrase that okay okay i
don't care
just kidding i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding no real talk
it's bad okay
i'm not for
it i'm not for i'm
shooting up drugs
shooting up of course not but even even
though the system the sibling thing i'm
like what the [ __ ] are you doing right
but that's my point is they're really
not that different no they're not in
terms of predisposing your child to
risks in terms of health genetic defects
and things like that and so
i know
maybe the parallel didn't make that
sense but like when you have some like a
relationship with somebody who's of the
same parents
the likelihood of you having genetic
defects in your child as a result are
extremely elevated
be it disabilities other kind of issues
like that and so
if you're con it's one thing if it
happens it's a different thing if you're
constantly doing that knowing those
risks are involved with the kid that
you're going to have
you know what i'm saying absolutely so
but like that has no effect on me but
i'm not going to be like yeah sure go
ahead no these two girls they lesbians
so whatever they're going to be they
want to source out sperm from
or whatever so i don't give a [ __ ]
obviously there's nothing
there's no incidents if you're lesbians
yeah there's actually
no incidents yeah unless
you take
your dad's semen then that's just [ __ ]
my dude
wish you could do anyways um at this
point at this point right but forget
someone being my sibling if i found out
the person i did if i woke up one day
and i might think they even looked like
were siblings
i heard that happened to me one time i
went on three dates for somebody i was
looking at her head one time like
my sister won't date you if you're my
age
she went
my sister will date you if you're
like her age or above all right no under
is fine
my age like that's me you know i mean
okay so the whole age is me
why are you putting my business up no
but she was once like that though let's
be clear yeah okay cool all right so
people wanted to ask me what i thought
about this story yeah
i think it's fake news i think it's
profitable to do stuff like this um you
know someone who talks about that girls
yeah well you thought but like or like
here's an example
if i was a a 45 year old woman doing
only things how about oh i started
having an affair with my grandchild put
up a put up i put up like a story about
that i take talk about that it goes
viral i have only things at the same
time and i do kind of grainy stuff
there's so many people going to pay
money to see that
so many because they go it's just free
exposure and it's mainstream exposure
right so everyone going yeah there's a
bunch going
yeah of course
that's the [ __ ] but i don't know what
the [ __ ] that was
how they going i'm not doing that [ __ ]
again
okay we'll replay it pause play right
now yeah of course
why don't we have an editor
you don't need to reduce it yeah just
play it again yeah just do it
but yeah so you guys are wondering
that's what's what's popping